[Music]
I'm so proud to be sitting here with a
repeat guests of the Pete Holmes show
Jim Jefferies from FX X's legit and also
a wonderful stand-up comedian good to
see Jim good to see you do you drink
coffee and I drink hot drinks so I want
something hot I'll have soup yeah soup
is a hot drink Jim I'm going to throw
this your way I like a room-temperature
to cold soup I'm fine with it yeah a
lovely cultured leftover soup yeah have
you ever gone in and you open up the
refrigerant there's some Chinese soup
cold you're single guy yeah yeah if you
got like that yeah because I have a
kidney a girlfriend and my fridges never
been more full and to be honest the
first time I left it like right in there
was the only time that I got I gotta go
crazy you really just blasted in the
just right way you put the gun in the
holes me and my friend decided to have a
child washed whilst on mushrooms wait
you had sex on mushrooms yeah yeah which
is always weird left your mushroom yeah
yeah and all the sports came out
mushroom baby greatest thing I've ever
done in my life okay I think I think I
did something illegal with my kid the
other day I think okay and I'm not sure
please cuz I didn't want it to be
illegal but this is just how it played
out right so every day I have a shower
because it's just the guy
I'm pleased makes you unique I'm
cleaning so I have a glass door and then
I normally wake up a bit after my
girlfriend my kid if if my girlfriend
hears I'm in the shower she lets him run
around upstairs and he always runs up
into it into the room and what I do is
sometimes like in the conversation I'll
draw a little suit on him I put a tie
huh
and then like and then I'll put a little
voice bubble out of him and says I love
dad so you write these names all right
Hank and I write H a and then when you
do the K you do it back the front you're
doing it right a lot of grown-ups
pretending to do a kid writing will do
like the first K backwards but then the
next one they'll fix it like the kid got
smarter like flowers for algernon know I
[Laughter]
only know three books I can't believe
that Roberts there's one professor at
home like oh I hope this show is
pedestrian now he loves it the speech
bubble of you sighs I don't know thing
are drawing some of that and then I get
out of shower and I go hey Hank like
that and he smacked me in the and
he ran away laughing just the conquer'd
she's at that heart I could start up
cousin naked in front of it with Hank
anyway boom and he read right now is it
is it illegal because he touched my
journals or is it illegal because I
didn't reprimand him and I laughed I'm
gonna say everything about this was
illegal but I didn't ask him - I didn't
- yeah when I get out of the shower I
come inside settle using a dog yeah I
don't give him any angle anymore all
right
I'm quick for a towel have you seen baby
toys they're all just Buzzard exactly
is lounder and hidden things this a bull
sack from fisher-price yes oh my god
microphone sex my second ball sack
exactly so you do is rooms dirtier that
I look like and white cover anything we
do like an old CD case right well that's
thick
[Music]